Donald Trump is the most corrupt
president even true and senator Bernie
Sanders political TV advertisements at
first glance seemingly the same as first
aired in Iowa in November last year and
the other on the right first aired in
North Dakota the day after former Vice
President Joe Biden swept a string of
southern states on Super Tuesday notice
the difference the most recent version
included images of African Americans but
the one on the left that first aired
more than four months earlier did not
making subtle changes to the same ad is
common practice with some of the
presidential campaigns and like others
we tracked this Bernie Sanders ad called
belong to us
saw at least six different changes as it
moved through the campaign calendar
using political ad tracker Kent RC mag
along with Facebook and Google's
transparency reports we tracked some of
the candidates ads to see how they
evolved over the campaign cycles a good
political ad is a mix of artistry math
and science Steve Israel served in
Congress for 16 years for four of those
years he was the chairman of the
Democratic Congressional Campaign
Committee and part of his job was to
make sure political ads resonated in
specific markets he is now the director
of Cornell University's Institute of
Politics and global affairs and teaches
a course that includes dissecting
political advertising an effective
political ad has to have several
components one it's got to be local it's
got to have music that reflects local
sensibilities the characters have to
project a certain tone a hard-driving
aggressive New Yorker is not going to do
well endorsing a congresswoman from Iowa
in that media market and most important
it's got to reflect data it's got to be
driven not by what some producer or a
candidate thinks will work but by what
the voters themselves tell you when we
started tracking the ads we focused on
some of the top candidates and also
included President Trump what we found
is that not all of the campaign's
actually had
different versions of the same ad one of
the reasons you repackage ads is to save
money so when you're not bound by a
tight campaign budget you can just
create new ones according to Kant RC mag
and data from Google and Facebook
Michael Bloomberg spent at least 590
million dollars on advertising over the
course of the presidential primary race
and had no different versions of the
same ad despite spending significantly
less money both senator Elizabeth Warren
and President Trump appeared to have no
variations of the same ad Tom Steyer
another billionaire in the race appeared
to only have one ad that had different
versions both Biden and former South
Bend mayor Pete Budaj edge appeared to
change several of their ads but had
fewer versions than others out of all
the ads we tracked it was Sanders and
senator Amy Klobuchar who made the most
changes we asked the campaign's about
their strategy
Warren's team chose not to comment and
while we didn't hear back from the
campaign's of Biden Budaj edge Klobuchar
and Trump the Bloomberg team told us
that having a large budget gave them the
freedom to create new ads for each
market the Steyr campaign told us that
the changes were made with no specific
intent and the Sanders campaign said
that they tailor ads to local markets we
picked out several differences among the
ads we tracked we then had Israel watch
some of them and analyze how the ads
evolved as they followed the candidate
on the campaign trail okay I'm looking
at one Bernie Sanders what happens those
are the people can argue represent no
more tax breaks for billionaires
we're gonna pause you do see in the
right-hand margin of the California
frame cleverly a little snippet of the
California State flag it's all about
local flavoring you cannot influence
people when you have a boilerplate ad
that is not going to resonate locally
across all the changes we noticed the
majority reflected the locality of where
the ad was aired as you continue to
watch the California ad you know you're
seeing more so it's now pulling out away
from that one woman now we see diversity
in this frame we see a young man we
still see young people it's a mostly
youthful crowd which tells me that
they're really trying to create this
narrative that this is not an old
candidate an old campaign we have the
support of the people and what people do
we have the support of young people in
San disease ad campaign could growing up
he used hospitality workers in the
California and North Carolina ad but
showed factory workers in the Iowa and
Nevada versions also in the North
Carolina version they added civil rights
as one of the important issues for his
campaign what this is telling us is that
in focus groups or in polling with the
demographic that senator Sanders was
trying to attract in a Super Tuesday
primary civil rights was a big deal and
so he chose to accentuate civil rights
if only for a few quick seconds he chose
to include that very graphic image in
order to create a bond a connection to
those voters who who care deeply about
the issue while Joe Biden had fewer
versions of the same ad we also saw his
campaign cater to the local market in
South Carolina the former vice president
would go on to win the state's primary
with strong support from its
african-american voters you are seeing
people real people authentic people
relating to Joe Biden in South Carolina
with t-shirts that everybody knows came
from South Carolina in a gym that is in
South Carolina and the u.s. framing
could be almost anywhere in the country
and those demographics are generally
chosen strategically 100 days 100 ways
with facebook versions of the candidates
ads we mainly saw just changes to the
size and other small tweaks to make them
work better on social platforms
however on Google's YouTube we noticed
some subtle differences in Sanders is
growing up at your you're seeing a
digital ad you're seeing this tight shot
of Bernie Sanders with his head kind of
slumped if you're watching a digital ad
you are engaged you have no choice when
a campaign commercial interrupts your
television preferences take a look at it
Bernie Sanders shoulders right like why
that because this guy has your problems
on his shoulders that's what this tells
me and I may be reading too much into it
so far this cycle it's yet to be seen
what new techniques might be used in the
political digital advertising space but
with sophisticated political campaign
companies like Michael Bloomberg's
hawkfish
vowing to use its resources for the
Democratic presidential nominee experts
are watching closely so if you are
living in Kenosha County Wisconsin which
is a swing county voted for Obama twice
and then Trump by less than a point
you're going to see hyper local Kenosha
County ads by Trump and the Democratic
nominee so both in content and visual
you're going to see very very localized
advertising in the presidential campaign